inflation hits the worst levels in 40
years as joe biden tries to play kissy
face with jimmy fallon and chen saki
assures parents they really do want
their children eating lunch off the
floor i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
ben um you may have noticed that
inflation rates are wildly out of
control now would be an excellent time
to diversify at least a little bit into
precious metals considering the
government is inflating the currency
basically into the ether whether they're
looking at your accounts or taxing your
unrealized gains the government will
come after your money they are very
creative when it comes to taking your
hard-earned money to fund their
expensive radical agenda i've said it
before i'll say it again you're making a
mistake if you're not diversifying your
savings hold gold in a tax shelter
account or keep gold in a safe at your
very own home i buy my gold from birch
gold is the only company i trust and
recommend and when you buy gold from
birch gold by december 23rd they'll send
you free gold for every 10 000 bucks you
purchase with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a plus rating with the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings today
text ben to 98 98 98 to claim
eligibility for their free gold with
purchase offer by december 23rd you know
one thing that has never been worth zero
no not lehman brothers gold text ben 298
98 98 protect your savings today the
government is interested mostly in the
government spending all of your money
and then maybe grabbing some more of
your money in order to pay for the fact
that they've spent all your money
already so you know what protect your
savings today with some gold from birch
gold text been to 98 98 98 protect your
savings today all right speaking of
inflation the statistics for the biden
administration are just egregious so
about the middle of last week you
started to see the biden administration
trot out a new line of propaganda their
new line of propaganda is that the
economy is actually going swimmingly
this is because the unemployment rates
are low well the unemployment rates are
low for a couple of reasons one people
have a lot of money in their bank
account because the government literally
just helicoptered cash to people last
year they just threw money at people and
so people actually have a lot of money
in their savings accounts right now that
is starting to dwindle as the
unemployment benefits have run and
you're starting to see people go back
into the workforce but this has created
a massive artificial shortage of labor
and because democrats keep pushing to
restructure the relationship between the
individual and the government there are
a lot of people who are sort of waiting
around thinking that the government is
going to pick up their tabs at this
point okay so that is problem number one
but the government is treating that as
solution because the unemployment rate
is low also there's a vast gap in the
unemployment rate between some of the
blue states and a lot of the red states
in fact all of the states that are best
on unemployment right now are red states
all the states that are worst on
unemployment are blue states that's
because the blue states continue to lock
down over cobit because they've decided
to panic their citizens with the promise
that government would be able to solve
this crisis when in fact government
really cannot solve the crisis beyond
making the vaccines available which they
did almost a year ago at this point all
the way back in february and march okay
so the biden administration is facing
down a lot of bad news the polling data
for them is really really bad so they
started to put out this no this line
that the economy actually you don't know
what's going on guys you don't know
what's going on
secretly the economy is really really
good there's only one problem the
economy is not really really good
inflation should not be spiraling out of
control this way according to the
washington post prices rose at the
fastest pace in nearly 40 years last
month 40 years increasing 6.8 over the
same period a year ago as inflation
continues to squeeze households and
businesses nationwide and complicates
the political environment for congress
and the white house that's one way of
saying that democrats are in serious
trouble according to the generic ballot
republicans are up 10 points in the
generic ballot right now and those
numbers rarely go the other way when the
when the party in power is already
trailing in the mid-year elections in
midterm elections
by the end of december of the year
before it almost never goes the other
way
there are very few exceptions to that
particular rule 2002 is one of those
rules and that's because of september
11th but generally the party in power
doesn't do well in the midterms and if
they're trailing it usually gets worse
for them before the election
consumer price index data released
friday by the bureau of labor statistics
showed that prices rose 0.8 percent in
november compared with october with
inflation spreading further throughout
the economy including to areas that had
not been as affected by the coronavirus
pandemic the november data marked the
largest 12-month increase since june
1982. during a period when inflation was
more of a scourge on daily life than
most millennials have ever known current
inflation dynamics have been spurred by
a devastating pandemic the royal global
economy upsetting the workforce and
supply chains et cetera et cetera et
cetera okay well actually if you were to
measure inflation by the same sort of
consumer price index that we used in
1980 the inflation year over year in the
united states is not 6.8 percent it's
like 14 percent okay this is
devastatingly bad and even the media
have been forced to cover it so here is
for example abc news is david muir
saying yeah we already know inflation is
high
you don't need us to tell you what
you're seeing already the new report out
tonight showing inflation is now near a
40-year high in this country consumer
prices up 0.8
last month alone year-to-year price is
up now 6.8 percent
americans are paying more for gas food
clothing and cars tonight president
biden acknowledging it is squeezing many
families across this country he pointed
to the pandemic the supply issues not
just in the us but around the world but
we know there are many moving parts on
this
okay and again it's not just david muir
abc's rebecca jarvis says this is not a
bump in the road but for all the talk
about the biden administration saying
that this is merely temporary this ain't
temporary
most economists do see these prices as
more than a bump in the road they expect
inflation to persist through next spring
and remember these supply chain issues
are global caused by the pandemic but
there are also as you point to labor
shortages issues of people many
americans waiting to return to work
until they see wages rise more
significantly having saved up 2 trillion
dollars throughout the course of the
pandemic by not dining out by not
traveling expectations are now that the
federal reserve will have to step in and
hike interest rates next year in order
to cool things up
so how much are the expenses up
according to cbs's news is nora
o'donnell expenses for the typical
family are up four
thousand dollars okay that's not a minor
bump in the road that's not a hiccup
four thousand dollars is a lot of money
for most people
prices were up 6.8 in november compared
to a year ago that is the biggest
increase in nearly 40 years the cost of
pretty much everything is surging food
gas electricity housing cars and clothes
and those who received raises this year
are seeing them wiped out by
skyrocketing costs listen to this by one
estimate expenses for a typical american
family have shot up by about four
thousand dollars in the past year
okay democrats are in real trouble here
because again all of their policies are
geared toward making this worse not
better we'll get to that in just one
moment first if you're looking for ways
to skip the trip to the post office this
season and dodge all that hectic holiday
shopping traffic why not save some time
and money with stamps.com stamps.com
lets you compare rates print labels
access exclusive discounts on ups and
usps services all year long it makes
sense especially if your business sends
more mail in packages during the
holidays which is pretty typical here at
daily wire we've been using stamps.com
since 2017 we are not going to be
wasting our time whether you're selling
online or running an office or side
hustle stamps.com can save you a lot of
time money and stress during the
holidays access all the post office and
ups shipping services you need without
taking the trip and get discounts you
can't find anywhere else like up to 40
off those usps shipping rates and 76 off
ups so you're saving time and you're
saving money and you don't have to swept
things over the post office what exactly
are you waiting for this is a very easy
call save time and money this holiday
season with stamps.com sign up with
promo code shapiro for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage digital skill no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code shapiro
again at stamps.com click that
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code shapiro okay so
the democrats are trying to maintain
that everything is fine that everything
is fine or they're trying to blame the
federal reserve but the reality is that
their policies are the big problem
there's an article from the washington
post yesterday it is titled in liberty
county workers who quit feel liberated
but the community discovers a powerful
downside oh you mean that paying people
to stay home leads to price inflated
inflation and shortages who could have
suspected such a thing except for anyone
with a functioning prefrontal cortex
according to the washington post maggie
towne quit her job as a hotel front desk
manager because the pandemic taught her
she could squeeze by without her
paycheck now home with her kids town
says her life is much improved but that
at the la quinta hotel she left an
exodus of housekeepers and front desk
workers forced owner hassel patel to
close the swimming pool and fitness
center and sharply reduce room cleaning
fannie lou bruton left her job as a cook
because she didn't want to be around so
many people anymore she realized she
said i did enough she's delighted that
the coveted pandemic drove her into
retirement but at isola's country cafe
where the staff has plummeted from 42 to
12 workers the owners had to eliminate
breakfast slash their hours and shut
entirely on sundays
liberty county a 45-minute drive
southwest of savannah is quit town usa
one of the many places across the
country where the pandemic slammed the
brakes on propulsive job growth and
startling numbers of people have quit
their jobs this year including more than
12 million americans this fall alone the
result according to business owners and
county officials is a place where people
are thinking about work in new sometimes
revelatory ways but also feeling the
pain of reduced services pinch bottom
lines and a diminished sense of
community
right because it turns out that the
left-wing dream that nobody ever works
anymore and then we all get to sit home
and finger paint jackson pollock that is
not real
people actually need work to feel
fulfilled also if you wish for there to
be productive goods and services for you
to trade with somebody else you need to
go to work
the left's dream which is that everybody
will basically stay home and the
government will cut them a check while
they watch soap operas is a ridiculous
and stupid dream it undermines actual
human flourishing
workers who have stepped away from
full-time jobs say the pandemic helped
them discover they can survive on
occasional gig work and government
benefits oh what can they well who pays
for those government benefits pray tell
could that be the rest of us who are
working
work harder millions on welfare depend
on you and bring back the 1970s bumper
stickers many liberty county residents
left minimum wage positions at
restaurants hotel and retail outlets to
take jobs at the county's burgeoning
warehouses and distribution centers the
upside as much as double the pay and
more flexibility in work hours the
downside severe strains of the mom and
pop businesses they quit and damaged or
severed long-standing social bonds
so yeah all the people who say they're
for small businesses have basically
wrecked small business across the
country there has never been a
dichotomous split in wealth like we've
seen during this pandemic
probably throughout human history
basically the middle class split into
people or at big corporations which did
pretty well during the course of the
pandemic
and welfare and if you're in the middle
if you're running a small mom-and-pop
shop if you're running a restaurant if
you took out your life savings and you
tried to build a business
and your business just wasn't large
enough to survive the government
shutdowns guess what you're out on your
ass
and the left is celebrating this they
think this is good
they think this is good
right it is not good okay it is very bad
and by the way it has bleed over effects
in terms of the inflation rate
and now you get the inflationary spiral
because why would you re-enter the
workforce unless you get a giant raise
but if you get a giant raise guess where
the prices are going to have to go in
order to pay for that giant raise and so
you get a wage price spiral that is what
is happening right now
the biden administration is trying to
downplay this pretending that it's not
really a big deal
in fact here is the president of the
united states joe biden trying to remain
alive saying that uh you know
inflation's really not that big a deal
this is joe biden over the weekend
you know the biggest
third of the increase in inflation is
used automobiles
um so i mean it is a real problem
but the point is that has to do with
supply chain as well but it also has to
do with the fact that not everybody's
looking for a used automobile but those
who are they're paying higher prices
because there's fewer of them because of
the cobit and what was sold out and the
like
okay so cream cream of wheat for both
mouth and brains the president of the
united states trying to downplay
inflation as used cars is insane at the
beginning used cars were driving some of
the inflation stats not anymore
what is driving the inflation stats at
this point is not even things like food
and gas
in the consumer price index absent food
and gas numbers is still extraordinarily
inflated
everyone knows this so he is lying to
you
and the thing is that not a lot of
people are believing it shenzhaki was
asked questions about inflation over the
weekend she didn't have much to say
about it she tried to avoid the
questions
given what jerome powell is now saying
does the administration does the
president acknowledge that inflation is
more entrenched and not transitory well
kristen i would say that
i can't speak obviously for jerome
powell but i think part of the point
here is that it doesn't really matter
what you call it
oh it doesn't oh okay also jen saki
added the prices are moving in the right
direction which is weird since last
month they headed in the wrong direction
[Music]
while we've seen costs increase in some
areas and we've seen
a good direct
move in a good direction in some areas
as well
what we need to do now is think about
what we're going to do about rising
costs what is our plan to address rising
costs
and what is their plan to address rising
costs they have a two-prong plan one is
to basically kick it over to the fed and
hope that the fed tapers and then they
can blame the fed for the sinking
economy as opposed to you know their own
bad policies and two spend more money so
over the weekend joe biden said we've
never had this kind of growth in 60
years but inflation is affecting
people's lives the reason why economists
think pill back butter is going to in
fact diminish the impact on inflation is
because it's reducing costs for ordinary
blood then
no it is not no it is not larry summers
who has been the voice of reason
throughout this entire inflationary
spiral you remember that he was the
treasury secretary under bill clinton
and he was saying early on when the
biden administration was pushing
a 1.9 trillion quote-unquote bailout
package that was absolutely unnecessary
in the aftermath of vaccine distribution
he said we're going to hit an
inflationary spiral and everybody
laughed at him because we truly have not
had a major inflationary spiral in the
united states for 40 years well now it's
back larry summers was right all y'all
were wrong and here's larry summers
saying yeah if joe biden got his
spending plans through there would be
more inflation not less
i think the inflation rate would be
slightly higher in 2022 and 2023
with the buildback better than it would
be with without the buildback better i
think over the longer term there might
be some effects that go that go
the other way but i think over the next
uh
couple of years the
what economists say ceteris paribus
other things equal it would raise the
inflation rate
okay he is correct okay now here's the
problem for the democrats they can't get
out of this without one of two things
happening
either joe biden stopping the spending
and allowing things to get back to
normal which they can't do because his
entire agenda is reliant on the idea
that he has to do something big he has
to keep pushing big things or the
federal reserve has to taper and taper
in really short order and when that
happens you'll see a spike in the
unemployment rate this is what happened
back when paul volcker did this in the
early 1980s and paul volcker had
actually been appointed to the federal
reserve by jimmy carter and he waited
until the reagan administration and you
really started to raise interest rates
and when that happened you saw a sharp
spike in the unemployment rate in the
united states because these two things
tend to happen when the federal reserve
makes it more difficult to borrow money
for banks banks start giving it out at
higher interest rates that means fewer
people borrow means less spending and
that means fewer jobs so now that you're
trapped in this cycle it's very
difficult to get out of that cycle
without some form of pain
and and that pain is coming now
presumably joe biden would like to blame
that pain you would imagine on the
federal reserve right at least he can't
blame himself well you know the federal
reserve they're independent they're
doing what they want they're just doing
what
okay but here's the bottom line the
american people are going to hold him
responsible because again this is his
economy none of this was necessary it
was not necessary this is not all supply
and chain problems this is a spending
problem this is a problem by the way
that is to a certain extent bipartisan
we should not have blown seven trillion
dollars into americans pockets last year
it's something we should not have done
but at least you could excuse that by
saying there are no vaccines available
so we have to try and keep people away
from from crowded areas and whatnot
by the time the vaccines were available
they were available in january once that
started to become widely available
february march there was no excuse for
what joe biden did they were going to
get to the federal reserve and what they
are probably going to do in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that if you're a responsible person you
need life insurance let's say that
you're responsible for a gang of of
children let's call them lost boys and
the former leader of your gang
has absconded it's just left for years
and years and years and you took over
and you're the responsible well finally
the leader the original leader he comes
back and he's going to lead you in a
battle against the big baddie and but
but you are tempted to fight the big
baddie yourself well as he chants at you
rufio
and as you approach him
you might be thinking yourself man well
at the very least i should have thought
about the lost boys and bought some life
insurance first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro answer a few
questions about yourself in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need compare personalized
quotes to find your best price you could
say 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
their licensed experts will help you
understand your options and apply for a
policy the policy genius team works for
you not the insurance companies you can
trust them to offer unbiased help and
advocate for you every step until you
are covered policy genius does not add
on extra fees or sell your information
to third parties head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro to get your
free life insurance quote see how much
you could save that's policygenius.com
shapiro again policygenius.com
so i think what's going to happen here
is not that the biden administration is
going to back off of their garbage
policy i think instead they're just
going to hope that the fed takes the hit
but here's the thing the fed is still
widely perceived as joe biden's fed
as it should be okay the notion that the
federal reserve is completely
independent from the executive branch is
crazy it has not been forever
the federal reserve is not some
independent group of people with the
best interest of the american public at
heart the federal reserve generally does
what an administration wants it to do
this is why for example donald trump
used to try to leverage the federal
reserve into lowering the interest rates
right he used to talk about maybe we
should go to zero interest rates maybe
we should they should go negative
interest rates and the federal reserve
predictably enough actually did go down
on the interest rates while trump was
president loose federal reserve monetary
policy is a bad thing
the federal reserve has not stuck to the
sort of milton friedman notion that we
should inflate the currency by a couple
percent a year
they've aimed for that but they've
generally failed because they're just
not that good at this it turns out
economists are not that great at being
able to read the full hand of the market
this is why i'm not a believer in the
federal reserve system other than
essentially guaranteeing bank deposits
but put that aside it's pretty clear at
this point what the bind administration
wants to do and that is make the fed do
the hard work
kevin warsh
writing over for the wall street journal
former member of the federal reserve
board he writes about how this really is
the federal reserve's fault he says
inflation is a choice it's a choice for
which the fed is chiefly responsible the
risk of an inflationary spiral arises
when policy makers first dismiss the
problem and then cast blame elsewhere
inflation becomes embedded in the price
formation process when the central bank
expellatedly or the insufficient
conviction to date the fed has acted as
an enabler
the sure sign of a problem when a
president gives voice to the scourge of
inflation and takes executive action
well before the central bank
acknowledges the severity of the
situation
supply chain bottlenecks is the
popularized rationalization for the
surge in prices but the supply chain
story sheds more shade than light
consumer prices are higher because
prices are rising at the point of
production assembly and transportation
this is a description of the state of
affairs not its source the fed's inertia
in withdrawing extraordinary monetary
policy amid full employment is the
proximate cause of surging prices when
monetary policy is too tight it slows
aggregate demand when monetary policy is
too loose it damages aggregate supply
extraordinarily aggressive monetary
policy namely quantitative easing
discourages investments in real est real
assets like capital equipment relative
to financial assets like stocks because
it takes a long time to see the
beneficial net effect of buying a really
expensive piece of equipment that
upgrades your business as opposed to
just buying stock which is running up in
price that's why non-residential capital
investment in the real economy things
like port modernization is running seven
percent below the pre-pandemic trend and
25 below trend since the advent of
quantitative easing a more exuberant
stock market and a less resilient real
economy are both consequences of the
fed's extant policy regime
by august 2020 the fed became impatient
with the purported low inflation rate of
ben bernanke and janet yellen chairman
jerome powell called low inflation the
preeminent economic challenge of our
time so the fed bet on a new policy
regime to get inflation higher it worked
it's not the first time a central bank
wanted a little more inflation and got a
lot more
last year in another break with
precedent the fed loudly and explicitly
endorsed a blowout in federal spending
congress swiftly agreed federal spending
increased from an average of about 21 of
gdp in the prior decade to more than 30
percent of gdp in 2020 and 2021.
national debt relative to gdp went from
79 in 2019 to over 100 today and the fed
bank rolled that fiscal profligacy
purchasing more than half of the new
treasury debt issued in that year call
it monetary dominance
none of this is a shock again the
federal reserve participated in this
inflationary run
and this is having already some pretty
negative effects right now we're stuck
in a trap okay because here's the
problem you raise the interest rates and
one of the things that happens is so do
you have now raised the rates on the
federal deficit okay if you're gonna pay
off the debt it's now more expensive to
pay off the debt
and again there are secondary effects to
the federal reserve's monetary policy
here according to the wall street
journal this year's inflation surge has
had a sometimes overlooked side effect
it means the federal reserve's interest
rate policy is providing even more fuel
to a hot economy the fed influencing
borrowing costs by controlling a
short-term lending rate called the
federal funds rate to stimulate the
economy it's been holding that rate near
near zero since last year but in
economic models it's the
inflation-adjusted or real interest rate
that matters most because inflation
reduces the value of future repayments
right like if i buy a bond and then
you're going to pay me off at a low
interest rate in the future if inflation
eats the complete interest rate i'm now
paying you for the benefit of having the
bond which is really not what you're
looking for
so it's going to be difficult and
painful to get out of this and meanwhile
you have the bite administration
continuing to push radical policy
according to the wall street journal
janet yellen is still pushing climate
politics from the treasury department
which of course means more spending
it means not following market forces
meanwhile the office of comptroller of
the currency and arm of the treasury
plans to issue a framework of its
expectations for how large banks should
be managing climate risk with detailed
guidance to follow next year
again all of this is not geared toward
good monetary policy it's not geared
toward good fiscal policy and joe biden
is going to pay the price from this
and then on top of that of course you
have all of this which has been excused
by the government pointing to covet but
there's no excuse for that as we'll get
into in just one second first let's talk
about your sleep quality if you've been
listening to the show for a while you've
probably heard me talk about my helix
sleep mattress helix sleep is great but
now that's not the only place you sleep
right or the only place you rest and
when it's time to chill out in the
evenings you're going to kick off your
shoes you're going to jump on that sofa
helix has gone beyond the bedroom they
are now making sofas they just launched
a new company it's called all form
they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs ship directly to your
door so what makes an all form sofa
really cool for starters it's the
easiest way you can customize the sofa
using premium materials at a fraction of
the cost of traditional stores you can
pick your fabric it is spill stain
scratch resistant the sofa color color
of the leg sofa size and shape make sure
it's perfect for you and your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can always start small and
buy more seats later on if you want your
all form sofa to grow and change with
you when you move all form sofas are
also delivered directly to your door in
the past if you wanted to order a sofa
you'd need to hire someone to come and
assemble it in your home or break your
back trying to put it together yourself
all form has simple quick assembly no
tools needed i've gotten all forms so if
i've got the three-seat sofa with chase
and the sand color with espresso legs it
is supremely comfortable and it's great
looking it's super durable which is
great because my kids wreck everything
if getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky you don't need to
worry you got 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it more than three months
if you don't love it they'll pick it up
for free give you a full refund makes a
great christmas present have a forever
warranty all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners at allform.com
to find your perfect so if i check out
allform.com
ben all right meanwhile the biden
administration is trying to claim of
course that all of this is because of
covet
right that warrant for covet everything
would be fine well here's the thing
kovid is the reason that the economy is
it had a massive artificial coma last
year which means that if you just leave
people alone the economy will go back to
normal but democrats were not interested
in that again it was not billed back to
where we were
it was
build back better was a bunch of garbage
you have no idea how to build an economy
an economy rests on fundamental precepts
about human nature
a well-planned economy is a is an
economy in which nothing is planned a
well-planned economy ironically enough
is an economy in which you understand
that the disparate sources of knowledge
outweigh any particular person's
expertise
so having one person at the top of the
economy dictating how funds are to be
spent is a complete waste of time and a
waste of money is a misallocation of
resources
countries that have centralized
economies learn this in all the areas
where they actually have centralization
this is why social welfare countries
like the scandinavian countries rely on
a capitalistic framework in order to
actually make the money then they
proceed to tax the money and blow the
money
but you have to have disparate sources
of knowledge providing for economic
progress and production in order to have
a growing economy but joe biden wasn't
interested in that he thinks the economy
distributes resources unfairly because
they should be distributed according to
race or according to victimization
status in the victim hierarchy or
whatever
joe biden believes that he is the great
master of fairness and so he has
intervened in the economy in dramatic
ways and he has done so on the basis of
blaming code but here's the thing covid
is for all intents and purposes not a
government issue anymore
okay there's a new study it came out
over the weekend cited by our friend
marty bacary from johns hopkins
university it was released by the
european center for disease prevention
and control and it found that there are
confirmed cases of omicron
in now 23 countries
okay how many of those cases have ended
in hospitalization or death zero the
answer is zero quote all cases for which
there is available information on
severity were either asymptomatic or
mild there have been no omicron related
deaths reported thus far as a friend
texted me over the weekend more people
have been killed by alec baldwin than
have been killed by omicron at this
point
okay so omicron is in fact maybe the
solution to the pandemic if it's more
infectious than delta and it kills no
one that's a good thing that means
everybody is gaining natural immunity
with asymptomatic or mild infection
so why are we panicking but we have to
panic because the panic is baked into
the cake because again at a certain
point this is no longer about protecting
people at a certain point that point
came long ago once we had the vaccines
at a certain point it's about control
and it's about maintaining a belief that
centralized sources of knowledge are
capable of fixing the world when that is
just not true so over the weekend yet
cnn medical expert jonathan jonathan
reiner calling for more measures with
regard to covet more measures with
regard to covert this is insane
the byte administration should mandate
vaccines for air travel in the united
states
vaccines are broadly popular in this
country 83 percent of adults have been
vaccinated i can't think of another
public policy measure in this country
where you have eighty three percent
agreement so seventeen percent of this
part of the united states
essentially is blocking
uh the this notion of a of a broad
vaccine mandate but unless we get more
people vaccinated
this virus is not going to go away
it's not going away anyway you all know
it's not going away anyway it's endemic
every scientist says it's endemic
they're they're not even aiming for
anything realistic at this point they're
aiming for control you know what a
federal vax mandate would do for flying
you know how what impact that would have
on covet zero it would have zero impact
you know why because planes are not the
chief vector of transmission
in fact staying in your home with your
family is the chief vector of
transmission if you get covered there's
a good time your spouse will get covered
and your kids will get covered if you're
on a plane they've got hepa filters
and throughout the pandemic i've been
corresponding with heads of major
airline industries and they've been
providing me their data airplanes were
never a main vector of transmission in
fact i'm unaware that there are any
cases in which a plane became a super
spreader event even though you are in a
flying steel
steel capsule in the sky that is filled
with farts even though that
you're still not going to get coveted
flying in a plane compared to being in
your own apartment with you or your own
house with your family
okay but they're still calling for more
measures why because again it's about
blaming these other people joe biden on
the economy wants to blame the fed even
though it's his own policy that has led
to the fed doing what it's doing and
we're the fed to raise interest rates
rather dramatically right now it would
cut into the economic recovery
and they know this cut it cut right into
the the unemployment numbers that joe
biden is busy bragging about it'll cut
into some of the stock market numbers
that joe biden is busy bragging about
and it will radically raise the price of
all the debt that joe biden hopes to
take in the future he's going to try and
blame it on the fed anyway okay but when
it comes to cova they've got to blame
somebody else they're blaming the 17
percent who are unfacts number one we
don't know how many of those people have
already had covered which means they
have natural immunity and number two
even if you're already vaccinated for
covid you can get coveted
i have friends to whom this has happened
many of them
yeah
you can still pass covid if you are
vaccinated
and yet they're still going to keep
pushing here's the nih is francis
collins saying give yourself a christmas
present get a booster okay unless you're
over the age of 50 the data on getting a
booster is pretty skimpy as far as
lowering hospitalization and death now
it may help you prevent in the short
term getting it in the same way that a
flu vaccine might help you
be prevented from getting a particular
strain of the flu
but it is not going to last forever
because your antibodies wane over time
here is uh here's the nih still pushing
boosters presumably for everybody
when you look at the evidence that
boosters do really give your immune
system a chance to resist delta and also
very new data from the uk also resist
omicron give yourself a christmas
present go get a booster dot don't wait
get it this week
that sounds like uh that's uh um why are
we honestly why are we focusing on
boosters at the expense of the original
vaccine the 17 who are unvaccinated are
unvaccinated everybody who's had two
shots and is not particularly vulnerable
just like with the original covet
variant
those people are not in serious trouble
everybody who is over the age of 50 65
maybe particularly 65 you should think
about getting a booster because
apparently the effectiveness against
hospitalization and death drops from the
90s down into the 70s
but again you're talking about marginal
decreases considering that a 70
reduction in hospitalization and death
is still pretty good okay beyond that if
you are young you might get coveted you
ain't gonna get hospitalized or die
after you've been vaccinated that's what
the stats show but they're still doing
and they're doing it with kids they're
doing with kids
this is crazy in one second we'll get to
the continuing panic in los angeles with
regard to school children which is
insane
i have a close friend who
told me
last week that he had covered and his
wife had covered and then his baby had
coveted and he got sick and his wife got
sick and the baby had a runny nose
you know why because that's what's been
happening the entire pandemic there are
73 million people in the united states
below the age of 18.
and of those 73 million people a grand
total of somewhere between 10 and 20
healthy individuals have died from covid
and yet we're still supposed to panic
we'll get some more the panic is the
point and then joe biden wonders why his
approval ratings are garbage maybe it's
because you made a promise and that
promise cannot be fulfilled you promised
you could fix the economy and you would
change how economics works for everyone
and it turns out all you did is just
blow things up and you promised that you
could get rid of covet and you can't
now listen i'm not blaming you for not
getting rid of kovad i'm blaming you for
making a stupid promise and you should
be held to that stupid promise if i
promise somebody that i'm literally
going to buy the moon and then i'm going
to present the moon to them as a
birthday gift
the the big problem is not that i didn't
present them the moon is birthday gift
the promise is that i'm an idiot for
promising them the moon
joe biden promised people impossible
crap is what democrats do routinely some
republicans do it too we'll fix all your
problems no you won't
no you won't because that's not the way
life works we'll get to more of this in
just one moment first let's talk about
the greatest gift of the holiday season
i'm taught particularly for dudes some
of the greatest gift of the holiday
season ladies get your man some steak
omaha steaks check them out right now
omahasteaks.com enter shapiro in the
search bar you can save over 50 when you
order the perfect gift package today so
what exactly is in that perfect gift
package you got four bacon wrapped filet
mignons four boneless chicken breasts
four omaha steaks burgers four gourmet
jumbo franks four individual scalloped
potatoes four caramel apple tartlets one
signature seasoning jar
and free eight omaha steaks burgers
that's for 99.99 that is a solid deal
right there omaha steaks is ready to
ship right now order the perfect gift
package today omahasteaks.com don't
forget get eight free burgers when
ordering if you use code shapiro in that
search bar and if you're a new customer
ordering for the first time enter
shapiro check out get 20
off select packages again you're going
to be saving 50 you're also going to get
that additional omaha steaks burgers
eight of them free with your order
achieving gift and greatness with omaha
steaks incredible flavor incredible
value 100
guaranteed omaha steaks.com keyword
shapiro go check them out right now
we're going to get into more from the
covid crazy left because it's getting
worse and worse and again
not boding well for joe biden first all
over the country people are waking up to
the tyrannical nature of joe biden's vax
mandates we here at the daily where
we've been leading the charge from
literally day one we said we were not
going to comply and we sued the biden
administration we were the first in the
nation to sue the biden administration
for their unconstitutional mandate we're
getting closer to a million signatures
on our do not comply petition every
single day because people are realizing
if we don't actively fight for freedom
the government will indeed take it
the biden vax mandates are falling down
in court we are going to try and deal
them the death blow with our lawsuit and
the signatures that we get are
demonstrating to the government that
there are just too many americans who
are not going to comply for their
nonsense mandates to actually effectuate
they have a goal of reaching one million
signatures which would provide a major
boost to our legal challenge we have
over 800 000 signatures so far we need
your help to cross the finish line
please sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply then share
our petition with all your friends and
family let's send a message so loud the
biden administration cannot ignore us
you're listening so the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so the coveted panic being driven by the
left is again not rooted in any data at
all and it's crazy it's crazy there were
reports over the course of last week
from people like michelle goldberg who's
a left-wing columnist for the new york
times that kids in new york city were
being forced in public schools to sit on
the floor separate from each other while
eating lunch i don't know why sitting on
the floor would prevent covid i don't
know the scientific rationale behind any
of those but jen sachi over the white
house she says that parents really do
appreciate these increased restrictions
parents appreciate it um
have you met a parent jen like any time
in any time in here you could you could
actually speak to some american parents
and ask whether they think it's a great
idea to incessantly mask their
five-year-old children and force them to
sit on the floor amidst the dirt in
order to eat their food
i will tell you i have a three-year-old
who goes to school sits outside for
snacks and lunch wears a mask inside and
it's no big deal to him i'm not saying
that's the case for everybody but these
are steps that schools are taking to
keep kids safe and i think the vast
majority of parents appreciate that
uh no the vast majority of parents do
not appreciate that at all at all at all
which is why you're seeing populations
fleeing from the northeast i can't tell
you how many people i've talked to even
in the past couple of months who are
looking at the insanity that is breaking
out in new york new jersey connecticut
when they're saying i'm leaving i'm
going to a free state where things
aren't crazy
and meanwhile in la hundreds of people
are fired online learning is set to
return amid vaccine resistance at lausd
and so as a graduate of value usd one of
the worst school districts in america i
can safely say that this is a bad idea
according to the washington post the
second largest school district in the
united states is facing mounting woes
over its cover vaccine mandate recently
terminating hundreds of employees who
refused to comply and vowing to put
thousands of unvaccinated students into
online classes board members of lausd
voted tuesday to terminate 496
employees who failed to get vaccinated
ahead of the deadline
we care deeply about all of our
employees at interim superintendent
megan reilly parting ways with
individuals who choose not to be
vaccinated is an extremely difficult but
necessary decision to ensure the safety
of all in our school communities really
um why is it necessary explain
scientifically why it is necessary to
fire people who have not complied with
your vaccine mandate when we know that
vaccinated people can pass covet and we
know that obikrant is coming which is
resistant in terms of vaccine
transmission
in addition some 34
000 students are in violation of the
requirements per the district's vaccine
policy students 12 and older must be
fully vaxxed by the start of the second
semester in january those who fail to do
so will not be allowed on school
campuses and will be referred to an
online independent study program which
means of course that we are going to see
some 35 000 kids just lost into the
system
and because
again i'm not a fan of lusd i think our
public school systems are a giant
failure but
you're now talking about kids who lost a
full year of school last year and are
going to lose another full year of
school at a time when vaccines are not
only widely available but kids never
suffered from this thing and the schools
never should have been closed
president biden wants more people to do
this he has called on state governors to
impose covet vaccine mandates for all
teachers and staffers as school
districts across the country have been
requiring the shots in an effort to slow
the viruses spread such requirements are
already established in oregon puerto
rico washington state and dc
in early september la became the largest
school district to take things a step
further requiring the vaccine for
eligible students
they're going to extend it probably
downward in age if they're doing it for
kids 12 and up why not for kids 5 and up
so they're going to completely break
lausd which is again
unintended consequences fine do it
all the kids will end up in parochial
school that's where kids will end up
and you know what good because these
public school systems suck they're
terrible
the only reason i'm angry about it is
because there are a lot of parents out
there who are paying a lot of tax money
so their kids can go to public school
and other kids can't even go to school
because the morons in lausd have decided
that your kid is at wild risk of covet
you by the way you see people on tv
saying this kind of crap all the time
you see commentators onto me well i have
a three-year-old and i'm really afraid
for my three-year-old really unless your
three-year-old has a significant
underlying condition i have no idea why
you would be afraid for your
three-year-old i have a one and a half
year old i'm not afraid for my one and a
half year old not one iota of the time
zero percent of the time am i afraid for
my 20 month old kid i'm not afraid for
my five-year-old i'm not afraid for my
seven-year-old i'm not afraid for any of
my kids when it comes to covid you know
why because kids are not dying from
covid
okay this lie that kids are in
widespread fashion dying from covet is
insane kids are dying from covid in
lower numbers than pretty much any other
cause of death in the united states at
this point
and yet you're still going crazy because
you got to maintain the lie you just got
to maintain the lie
and we can all see where it's going if
you look abroad you can see how crazy
they've gone in australia they're
rounding people up who are not
vaccinated in germany there was tape
that emerged over the weekend of the
german police measuring the distances
between people outside with folding
rulers to make sure that you were a
proper space
away from people
i mean this video is insane they're
literally walking around with sticks
trying to measure the distance between
individuals to ensure that you are far
enough away from others
outside
have you seen the stadiums in the united
states that are filled with people for
for college football and no transmission
this is madness
americans are not into this and if you
are into this fine stay in a blue state
and enjoy yourself
well maybe all of this has to do with
joe biden's
completely cratering approval ratings
this guy entered office in the 50s
he was given the gift of a vaccine that
he did not develop
there was a distribution plan that he
did not develop he took advantage of
that all he had to do was not be
terrible at this it's incredible it
really is in life it is incredible how
much of being successful is just staying
out of the way of success but people
can't do it they got to get their grubby
little hands in there and joe biden had
to get his grubby little hands into the
economy and into coveted policy had to
demonstrate that he was an important
person and it made him feel important
well guess what the american people are
about to make him feel pretty damned
unimportant in the midterm elections so
joe biden decided he was going to go on
with one of his late night sycophants
this one was jimmy fallon i remember a
time when jimmy fallon used to be at
least somewhat humorous and then trump
broke his brain and all you've got now
is sort of the
feeble husk of jimmy fallon performing
bad stephen colbert knockoff interviews
so here he was with joe biden doing an
interview and and sucking up to him it
was not good guys
how much do you pay attention to
approval ratings well not anymore
[Laughter]
hey you can always
my favorite thing about politicians is
their tells they're really fun so you've
got comment comment harrison tell us the
actual crazy laugh joe bidens tell us
that after he thinks that he told a joke
he wipes his eye like this this is the
thing that you watch for it it's kind of
fun okay and uh and that and jimmy
fallon's tell is that he has one of the
worst fake laughs in the industry it's a
i mean it's like kamala harris level
fake laugh yeah but it didn't stop there
then you had jimmy fallon again they're
trying to prop up this old man because
they got nothing nothing so here is
jimmy fallon praising joe biden for no
reason anyone can discern
a lot of republicans and democrats used
should get really unwell together for
example one of the reasons i'm a little
bit late
coming on is it because uh not coming on
but to do the taping here is because i
did bob dole's eulogy today he asked me
on his deathbed whether i would do his
eulogy we're friends we disagreed but
we're friends we gave you standing
ovation because i go here he is he's
bringing class back
he's the classy guy and you're bringing
class back to the office and i thought
it was
amazing that you did that
well it's it's so so much class being
brought back to the office by the way in
the same interview joe biden started
ripping on republicans and on his
political opponents as anti-vaxx crazies
and suggesting that everything that's
going on is their fault so much class so
much class from joe biden
guess what the american people are not
falling for this they don't buy it and
here's the problem for democrats they
got nothing behind joe biden he's the
only thing standing between them and
complete collapse kamala harris is a
disaster area and now her team is
fighting back by saying that everyone
who points this out as a racist or
sexist good luck with that particular
line of argumentation
according to the new york times
addressing reporters at a meeting of the
democratic governors association
governor roy cooper of north carolina
gave an emphatic answer when asked
whether he expected joe biden to seek a
second term and whether he believed that
was in the best interest of his party i
do and i do said cooper i fully expect
him to seek reelection and i will
support him in fact we're gonna win
north carolina for him but three minutes
later cooper was sketching out what
could be the makings of a cooper for
president primary message he trumpeted
his repeal of the state's so-called
bathroom bill targeting transgender
people an executive order granting paid
parental leave to state employees
another order putting north carolina on
a path to carbon neutrality by 2050.
publicly cooper and other democrats are
focused on what will be a difficult
2022. however it's 2024 that's
increasingly on the minds of a long
roster of ambitious democrats and their
advisors
no one is interested in kamala harris
she's a giant failure
pete booty judge is a complete nothing
bag senator elizabeth warren is 8 000
years old and blew it last time
amy klobuchar has no jews
it's it's it's
their bench is so weak it's so insanely
weak
and many of the people who theoretically
might be better for them you know the
moderates who might replace joe barr joe
biden people like mitch landrieu former
mayor of new orleans
that that dog is not going to hunt in a
radicalized democratic party
so good luck guys i mean by the way how
bad are things for harris jensachi was
asked if kamala harris who was you
remember put in charge of mexico policy
our border policy with mexico if she had
ever been in contact with mexico ever
and uh saki was like uh no
is the administration um reaching out to
mexico to partners in central america
this morning does this cause for a
certain reevaluation of the strategy to
deter migration norm it would really
come through the department of homeland
security of that kind of outreach so i
would point you to them for any more
detail about a connection with the
mexican government
yeah so we have no idea we just no we
have no idea whether there's been any
contact with the mexican government at
all at the at the white house level so
really really solid stuff
again the the thing is this the national
policy the democrats are pursuing it's
not that that national policy has
created these crises all over the united
states on a broad level it's it's
facilitated them but we don't have these
crises down in florida right we don't
have an economic crisis down in florida
we don't have a covert crisis down in
florida and things are going pretty well
down here we've got inflation our
inflation is a national phenomenon it's
not a regional phenomenon but a lot of
the problems that the democrats have
created are local in nature the problem
is that we can all see that the bad
democratic policy at the local level
bled up to the national level and then
the democrats at the national level
attempt to impose it broadly
so for example we now see the murder
rates skyrocketing in major cities all
over the united states we don't live in
a major city in the united states
where we live we live in south florida
but we're not living inside a major city
we're not living in a major blue area
which means that we're not feeling the
impact of this but when you turn on the
news and you see a radical uptick in
crime
nearly everywhere that blue government
predominates you start to think maybe
these people shouldn't be in charge of
government policy
by the way how bad are things in los
angeles where i used to live things are
so bad in los angeles that the lapd is
warning people to stay away that's how
bad things have become in los angeles
according to cbs news
murder rates continue to soar nationwide
portland oregon is grappling with a
record number austin louisville and
rochester have all seen homicides more
than double in just a couple years with
violent crime rising in los angeles the
head of the police union warns if you
can stay away
we can't guarantee your safety it is
really really out of control
we cannot guarantee your safety in los
angeles
and my family and i escaped los angeles
and we've been telling people since get
the hell out that place is gone is that
the kind of government anybody wants
nationally i have serious doubts
so democrats have a choice they can
either continue to pursue the policies
they like
to their own political detriment and
turn themselves into a joke or they can
abandon that stuff
i will
give you one guess as to which way
they're going to turn alrighty we will
be back here later today with an
additional hour of content first let me
remind you you need to go sign our do
not comply petition we have close to 850
000 signatures on it head on over to
dailywire.com
do not comply in the meantime go check
out the michael noel show that's
available right now i'm benchmark this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina her
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
dr fauci says that your unvaxed kids
might die kamala hara says that women in
post row america will die and jesse
smilet is going to jail for pretending
that he almost died check it out on the
michael knowles show
[Music]